uh i will just sing in the start of my
streams
so that at least i'm doing something
hopefully that's not too much of a
problem
hopefully it's not too terrible
it should even itself out hopefully i'm
having internet issues lately for sure
but
hello everyone i'm alana i am joined by
greg and
mark and we are here to talk about the
snyder
cut uh as we all have appropriate
backgrounds
you can see so i guess we're going to
start real general
uh greg just as broad as you like hello
what did you think i liked it
i liked it a lot uh i am the
kind of dc fan and superman fan and
justice league fan
who has been wandering in the desert for
years and will drink the sand
and so like what i always talk about
especially introduce myself to people
who haven't heard me rant about the
snyder verse before is always
this is not the dc cinematic universe
i would want that i would have pitched
but i appreciate for what it is and for
me it's always another elseworlds book
right
which of course if you're not aware uh
you know when dc would do these you have
his continuity it would then have
elseworld stories that were one-off
stuff your creators telling their story
there's man of steel batman be superman
into this but
as i'm sure we'll get into it i have
many my issues always fall on the
shoulders of warner brothers
and their non-committal attitude to what
the dceu
is and thus making it a watered down not
fun time
that okay yeah that's it's a lot and i
mostly agree with you
uh mock how about you there's a lot for
me
uh okay so how did i feel about this
movie
i uh i didn't like it
i appreciate it though like i appreciate
it in the same way
that i appreciate jack kirby's new gods
you know from which
this film draws much of its inspiration
which is
a lot of that stuff is kind of
impenetrable and a little graphy but
it's also the way comics often work
and often work when they're at their
best with no filter
you get amazing stuff by the way you get
part of the duck that way you get
new gods that way you get ronin that way
um
and that's that comics is vibrating on
its own frequency and its own level of
crackle and that stuff is amazing
and this is the closest i've ever seen
whether you want this or not it's spared
no expense
and so i appreciate it on that level but
i
i i found myself really struggling to
engage with it
on a sort of narrative emotional level
um
for any number of reasons i'm sure which
we'll we'll dig into
but like i'm glad it exists um
and yet i also never needed it to exist
so i i
i'm kind of in the phantom zone on this
movie
if that makes any sense i definitely
went into it with the same thought of
like
i don't know that i need this to exist
and i i agree with greg that i have
as a huge dc fan dc issues in general
which span
well when it comes to the movies it's
mostly that i feel like they jump
straight to end game
we didn't get all of the proper origin
story films that i would have really
liked to have seen
and i think that even in the snyder cut
that means it's four hours long because
we're getting an origin story mostly for
cyborg which i actually thought was
largely pretty good there was some stuff
in there that i didn't quite buy but
that could have been its own movie
entirely
and then i could have cared about all of
these people more like the batman in
this universe
i do not care about and for me to say
that as someone who has like a batman's
point
how many stats too many is is a lot for
me
to be like this batman is really dumb
he's he makes a lot of bad calls like i
just don't buy anything
and i think that that's just a result of
like having all of these characters who
don't have their own films fleshed out
to be fleshed out
all at once uh but that said because
some of that stuff did happen in this
movie
i feel like this made way more sense
than the original justice league like
comparing them side by side i was like
oh this this story i get i feel
i still think that steppenwolf is pretty
uninteresting
but uh all of the context surrounding
that that isn't explained in a
five-minute
terribly voice-acted gal godot uh
exposition dump
uh like did make a lot more sense to me
i was like okay i got what the boxes are
doing i get the plan
i get this anti-life equation i
understand the points you're making here
but before i was like i don't even
really know why we're doing any of this
[ __ ] so
overall four hours but the plot made
more sense
which i'll take hold on you you got the
anti-life equation
i got that it was important
that it's supposed to be coming here
what what is why these
like you just want a terraform because
it didn't even really occur to me that
they didn't explain it previously until
watching this one and i was like oh
okay well he wants this equation real
bad he's a big fan of math
here we are
you know for everyone who talks about
zack snyder's work i think they're
always like well this is his problem
and then they say what a menagerie of
things but
in all are equally problems for me
especially talking about anti-life right
here right is the same thing as when we
talked about the nightmare sequence and
so he looked at this
five movie thing he was making and was
putting in things going
like oh well it won't be explained in
this movie but it'll be explained in two
movies three movies and then you'll get
that aha moment
which so does not work for a cinematic
audience like
you know when i remember watching batman
v superman finishing it getting into the
car
and being like oh my god flash scene was
so cool
and tim going that was so dumb like what
positions all the time of what he's
doing and i think anti-life's another
great equation where
a great great example where when we
finished it or when i finished it and
then was excited to talk to people i was
like and i was so excited to see the
ansel education and everybody was like
what does it what is it like what are
they talking i'm like oh well
and it's like that's so not a a great
answer to give somebody
to be like oh if you're not like you're
talking about mark right if you're not
up to date on the new gods if you're not
wondering about this if you didn't read
this
if you didn't know that like well like
i'm popping for granny goodness popping
up in the boom tube right
a lot of people are very excited about
that
yeah it's uh it's a strange thing to no
go ahead
no i was just gonna say you know it's it
is a it is an odd narrative decision
to kind of strand an audience that
doesn't know this stuff and and if you
think about i'm not
to compare it to marvel because i feel
like that way lies madness
but if you if you look at say the lord
of the rings trilogy which is
we know we're making three of these
right and we know we have to invest an
audience
they find ways to reset that story and
tell you exactly what you're after
exactly who these characters are then
you get to load a bunch of other stuff
on top of that
but you know i think to your point greg
he even though he had a five movie plan
not realizing that you had to make every
movie
like gum proof like you know it's the
old stanley
ethos of every cow engaged with the
content and then go with you for a while
and if you're all wanting to do that i
agree
i i just i think the inclusion of it one
of the reasons you have that mashup
i have lag again don't i it's it's my
internet i clearly have laggy
i'm sorry greg this is the second time
in a week that we've talking over people
it's my bad sorry go ahead
i can just see it and i'm like you know
it's fine it's totally on my end
how dare you make points um i know i was
going to say the anti-life thing is like
it is a thing that i i i would agree it
like is not well fleshed out
it does not pay off in the end it just
made more sense of why the invasion
was happening and why steppenwolf needed
to do it uh because otherwise the motive
is just kind of
terraform planets which is so
uninteresting for your villain to be
doing
so adding like this this thing that's on
this planet somewhere that we need to
find
i felt like at least added a little bit
more and i i mean i liked that
steppenwolf was serving
someone as well i feel like that like
still tries to to make that villain a
little bit more interesting where
previously like that's that's virtually
all not there assuming i remember him
correctly he he
he isn't in the right okay just wanted
to make sure
it's been a while he was terrible
extremely uninteresting
on the head and i feel like they uh yeah
and that's i mean
go ahead go ahead no please go ahead
for like that's what i'm saying in terms
of like yeah you're nailing it i'm like
i think cyborg was so much better in
this film but then yeah steppenwolf
i really liked in this one and i liked
it from the jump of like
cool you know he's an underling the dark
side and you also know he [ __ ] up
and like this is his thing now i'm
trying to get back and assad is just you
know mouthing him and tell him he's got
to
get
whatever 50 000 500 000 more planets or
whatever and like
you see i thought built up so nicely
again if you knew something about it and
like are
weird and obsessive like me great but if
you didn't even you saw it and there's
that i think great scene and again
this is when you talk about the
menagerie of things people want to
criticize zack snyder for right like
if you remove scenes or imagery and you
put them out people are like oh that's
great but then the stuff around it or
the melodramatic or whatever
but that scene where he's talking to
assad and he's like hey i found
anti-life equation down here and assad
starts talking the alien language and
then
leaves the weird face time they have all
the paradigms dropped to
what are you doing and then it's dark
side and he drops and he panics and i
thought they did such a great job of
giving steppenwolf a weird he's a bad
guy and he sucks but arranged to it
whereas yeah in the weeden cut right he
is
he just shows up he wants some other
boxes and he's going to terraform the
earth and he's like what is this what
are you talking about
yeah i do feel like there's there's the
version of steppenwolf
this version which actually has more
character motivation and clarity
than say no this is still just like why
come like what are you doing oh
this is very weird um i think that he
works well
as comedic relief but uh man that moment
where you're saving someone and he
brushes her hair
i was like oh no why have we done that
with him
that's a bit much you didn't you could
have just saved it
not a huge fan of that yeah i don't like
any of this
uh just some some really weird character
choices that i think is like the the
thing that hurts the whole thing for me
the most
is not caring about these characters
thinking batman is really dumb
uh thinking like a wonder woman is again
just exposition dumps a lot of the time
um and when you see her in the museum
doing her job at the start
you can clearly tell nobody told her
what she's supposed to be doing she's
just like kind of brushing at things but
absent-mindedly not actually like doing
anything at all
um a lot of just like really loose ends
for me
yeah it was made in 1984. yeah
yeah that's rough yeah right and yeah i
think that's the thing where there's
you know i think it was nick on our
interview on kind of funny that was
talking about like
it seems like the movie does something
right and then immediately does
something wrong right so you just can't
get in this vibe with it ever because
it's like oh that's great and then like
yeah like i think
the flash scene is a great example right
where it's it's additive
it's okay cool him and her have a moment
passing going to the pet shop all right
that's fine but let that
build in the background for the flash
movie or whatever and then that moment
where it all starts and he
turns and his shoes explode i thought
that was the door and he pushes
through i thought it was awesome all
this is the good stuff pushes through it
and goes
and then this weird song starts playing
and you're like
this is a choice that's taking me out of
it all of a sudden as i listen
to what is this song and then yeah he
gets there and he's like turning her and
do it and it's like oh this is a
you had one you just looked at each
other and then you made eyes again when
she was driving away i get it but like
you've taken it a step too far now barry
right and then the smash down the
the back to the dogs it's like okay you
it's this rocky roller coaster all the
time of something that's really cool i
think it looks
fantastic and then into this weird thing
of like wait why are we doing this yeah
because it also doesn't
add anything really to his character you
know because we're never gonna see iris
again
like so we're gonna spend like five six
minutes in this sequence that does not
have anything to do with the rest of the
movie
you could do that sequence where we
explain how he gets powers
which just suddenly exists and before he
has his job at the crime lab
which is how he did this according to
hoyle gets his powers
and i was like oh well let's connect
this to something let's let's make it
fuel something are we going to see iris
again if so this makes sense
if we're never going to see her again
wouldn't this also just
couldn't this real estate have been
spent connecting us and connecting him
to the main narrative a bit more
honestly the
the moment his dad took you know the the
bullet for him couldn't it be
some ammunition for who he is it's it's
very much
and i know you know i know you want to
stay away from the mcu comparisons i
will always go full bore
right especially as dc fanboy number one
of like i know i wish dc
cinematic universe was like the mcu but
it's they're trying to do
with what they do with spider-man
homecoming with flash where they're like
oh no
you get it and the audience is like what
no i actually don't get it
how is this guy fast like is he an alien
or what's going on
like there's no real explanation for
that we haven't seen the
his origin story like 900 times like we
have with pete's
totally it's like if you're going to
have him at some point explain that
there's a rule that says he can never
time travel
then show us how he broke that rule to
bad effect right yeah that's a really
good point that one stood out to me
he's like when i get close to the speed
of light weird stuff happens with time
and you're like
all right and then he's like i have time
to break the rule and i'm like again
what's the consequence exactly the scene
of him going
you gotta break the rule barry and
vibrating as everything explodes and
becomes apocalypse around him right
like take it out of context and put out
like i think the scene is awesome
you know him vibrant all right we got a
breakthrough rule go and he's talking to
his dad like wow this is powerful but
then you put it in this movie you're
like
but like so has he has he [ __ ] up time
before and like
is this going to mess up going forward
what does it mean i completely agree
like some of that stuff looks so cool i
remember even seeing the
uh first release of the film i don't
know what to call it original feels like
weird to say but uh when the moment when
uh
superman looks when flash is running
past him i was like
ah like i thought that was just so so so
cool but then it's still like
in the context of this scene this is the
thing that like maybe i'm missing
something that someone can inform me of
the fact that that fight starts because
cyborg's suit in that one instance
detected a threat
and he couldn't control it i was like
that's how this went down is that he's
like oh this one time i'm gonna shoot
cannons that i can't have any control
over accidentally because superman's in
front of me
your dad kind of played you there if he
built that into your suit
you did not have any control over that's
a bad idea and i feel like that
happening goes against like him
the machine he's supposed to be the
machine we are told he is that being the
lead-in to that scene i was like i don't
understand how this has happened is this
is there something i'm missing there
yeah it's from the idea right is that
the mother box
components have fused with him so he's
not he
when silas brought that over he's not
like
fully in control he's inhabiting a space
that is using so it's the mother box
seeing superman as a threat rather than
the suit exactly
interesting in the scene where the
parademon com is outside the window and
like the homeless people and the cops
scare it off
like cyborg's hand becomes becomes the
cannon he looks at me
he's surprised like it's uh instinct
it's and it's the box truck or whatever
the tech inside of him trying to protect
itself from a kryptonian threat
appreciate that explanation that does
make a lot more sense it's
yeah yeah it's one of the few things i
think where uh
not that it did it better but whedon's
cut i thought did a little bit more with
that of him being like i don't fully
understand this stuff and i don't know
what's going on
yeah and i think that that is a hang
over there where it made a little bit of
sense that way
yeah i think that that sequence is one
of the few times i think that that
the justice league um that
the tweaks on that scene work better
than the original i don't think there's
much you can say about the new
the new material of the jazz shot that
is worth preserving because it's not
very good at all
but that like dark superman fight yeah
the way in is a little bit better and
the way out is a bit stronger where in
joss's version
bruce wayne decided to bring lois lane
to the stage because
he knew like being the batman you kind
of want him to be
he thought three steps ahead realized
that maybe the only thing that'll stop
him from just
mowing us down like so many aaron weeds
is the woman he loves
and so that's his secret weapon whereas
now she just happens to be buying coffee
for a cop who happens to be posted
outside this
you know heroes plaza and so yay good
thing she's here
we all would have died if she wasn't
yeah right she's sick that day right
like
something to do with the pregnancy test
before that i felt like that just that
whole sequence was a lot weaker despite
still thinking
that the slo-mo scene of superman
turning his head and that being just you
know
snyder in essence is still so freaking
cool
like just just so hype in that moment
but everything surrounding that i was
like
i feel like i don't buy any of this
happening and i i
just really wish like on my most
subjective level that they hadn't made
batman smarter
anywhere i feel like he's useless and
like all this effort that they're
putting into building this
this ship effectively they'd like that
we need to get this working
um for what she wants to fly but why
like what is that really what you need
to be doing
but this private jet can't fly
i can't get the batmobile inside this
private ship
yeah no and that's the thing i i find
you know
weird about this one in particular and i
know it's you know
whoever you talk to about bvs is a
different conversation but
i like ben affleck's bruce wayne in this
justice league
i don't like his batman and i liked his
batman fine in
bvs again to your point a lot it's still
like not the smartest batman right of
like he gets played by lex in bbs and
sets up
like he can have a conversation with
superman superman of course if he just
doesn't shove batman and the fight in
bvs just talks to him right there the
whole movie's over it doesn't matter
but it's this idea of the batman you get
in snyder's justice league like
i just don't ever feel he looks
comfortable in the costume
and it is i don't know if it's that
juxtaposition of him being
with other heroes now and other super
powered people that it just looks like
ben affleck in a suit
but he he seems stiffer than ever he's
not doing cool stuff he's mainly using
himself as a distraction which i could
understand in terms of like fighting
better humans and doing things
but his bruce wayne i liked fine of you
know going to collect people having
these conversations
doing all this stuff but the actual
batman stuff i didn't dig and vibe with
but oddly i like nightmare batman but
again that's just talking so it's
different
the first time that you actually see him
take his little mask thing off
there's a film mistake um where
he he doesn't know which order to take
things off in so he pulls his hood down
and then he goes through his glasses and
then he pulls his mask down and then he
pulls his hood down so you see him go
like you watch that happen is that is an
actor
not knowing which one to do in which
order and you watch it and it's like
such like a
i i agree he just doesn't seem
comfortable like just across the board
and i feel like it's almost like he
didn't play batman he played bruce wayne
in a suit
like the whole time yeah um which is
definitely an issue there but again i
think that also comes into the writing
in a lot of cases of like batman just in
this case being sort of dumb
she's not a good guy and it sucks
because like i and i love your take on a
lot i know what a big batman fan you are
like there's so many cool threads to it
that i would have loved if seen explored
right and it is that like you know the
way the reason the whole nightmare
thing's tacked on is like
let's give you a little bit of what we
wanted to do with the what happened
there robin that got killed right but
having the robin suit there
that a great conversation in bvs right
where he's like you know in 20 years in
gotham how many
how many of the good guys are still
around and how many stayed good like
talking alpha like
that batman seen [ __ ] and i feel like
there could have been
so many interesting conversations there
in alfred maybe not even being part of
it anymore but coming back and like
you're using guns you're killing people
like you've gone against everything you
stood for and like
talking about how he lost his way in 20
years but
they never do so it's left for us to sit
there and be like oh well he lost his
weight he's like well diddy like
it's never made out to be that and then
of course the light switch flip that
becomes the justice league of like
i swore a promise to him on his grave
and it's like bro you hated him like you
know what i mean and i understand you
got duke but this is still a quick turn
to be like i get it now like so there's
all these things that like the movie
wrestles with and tries to
mature and not have it be super heroey
and i have it be comic bookie but then
it has these
literal comic book page flips where it
has to be the most superficial
absolutely it does there are there are
shots that i was like
that's a comic book shot and it happens
all the time in the action sequences but
in ways that i appreciate them like that
was not necessary i did not need to see
any of this for storytelling purposes
but you took this as a frame in a comic
book and you were like we like it
put it in there and that's a lot of that
visual stuff is really fun
yeah i mean zack absolutely directs and
splash pages which i i 100
appreciate yeah but it's the connective
tissue between those splash pages
that i always kind of wrestle with you
know and i think to your point
i especially bvs there's there's moments
when they're like oh no i've been doing
this for 20 years off
i know what i've seen and then like
nobody in metropolis seems to know who
batman is
yeah what's like is he a brand new guy
is he not a brand new guy like
i knew about son of sam you know killing
people on the other side of the country
how do you not know a dude across the
bay is masquerading as a bat like
how did he was clark hit and not
understand like
who are you lex luthor you know like the
richest person in the world and bruce
wayne never met that guy before
is he famous like who what are the
relationships between these people and
how do those relationships inform
how they act with each other and it's
it's always
weird finding that push and pull in
these movies of when
when the filmmakers choose to engage
with that and when they just kind of
just blindly skip past it to get to the
next time we get to punch people
yeah i feel like sometimes that's a
preference thing where i feel like
i like stories that have complex
characters but relatively simple plots
and this is a story that focused on a
plot more so than the characters in
their relationships that's definitely
what it feels like to me at least it's
like here is the plot and here is the
action that serves that plot but it
didn't
really explore the relationships between
the characters um again with the note
that it does cyborg
like infinitely more justice overall um
but but to that note mark i really
wanted to ask how did you feel about the
uh batman
joker dream sequence
i i kept on having problems in this
movie
you know and maybe it's a failing of my
own in which case i will cop to it
but understanding how we keep dipping
into these weird alternate reality
future visions like we've seen in the
future in this moment is it still bruce
wayne how is he seeing the future are
they real teachers he's just dreaming
suddenly oh okay so now victor stone is
also seeing the future but that's
motherbox future like oh
okay i guess there's nine different ways
people can be seen in the future
um i it it didn't really
do very much for me beyond the little
tantalizing nature of
batman and joker and now both alive in
this future and working together
and like oh that's kind of cool i would
have loved a movie that helped me this
relationship between these two as
opposed to just
you know like this weird dessert for a
meal i didn't order or expect
like oh i'm at a chinese place and
they're bringing me cannolis and that's
weird but i like family
[Laughter]
but sure i'll bother like it was just
another sort of thing that
like clearly seemed cool in the moment
and i feel like a lot of this movie is
about what could be cool right here
as opposed to what is a logical sort of
scene after the one we just saw like
like nothing seems to be informing
anything else
beyond that's cool right like yeah man
let's do that
which on like a 15 year old level i
thoroughly appreciate
how about you greg how did you feel
about it
yeah i mean i agree with what mark's
saying right especially again we're
talking about things that are cool in
the moment and then you stop and you sit
there you
deconstruct it for a second right all
that said i i loved it i
i like i was sitting out here watching
it you know 1 30 in the morning
we had had screener access or whatever
and like i have the volume at a
reasonable level and as soon as that
started
i did like the like i got off the couch
and like sat in front of the tv
to get as close as i could to the
speaker to listen and hang on every word
like
it's what we're talking about and i
again i would love a movie
based in that and you know obviously
you're supposed to get one and i would
love the
build up to it and it's back to the 20
years in gotham it's back to the robin
suit like
it was fan service and i ate it up like
i enjoy i love that like i didn't see
mira coming right and then she's like
you know
he'll die for what he did to arthur and
they're having that conversation and
then yeah
to just get batman talking to joker and
have it be
this for i you know i think obviously
suicide squad and
the air cut is a completely different
conversation but like you know i
obviously don't think jared leto was
used well in that uh movie and i also
don't think he got
a real chance to swing the bat i think
for what they gave him and said to do
and like whatever ideas they came up
with to make that joker
like i would have liked to have seen him
do more of what he did here and so to
have him be
except for the reach around line which
even in the movie they when they cut the
batman even batman's like what the
what is he talking about like why are we
saying all right yeah anyways back to
the scene
like having them talk about uh robin
right and boy wonder
the true spruce thing and like even
batman cursing like make no mistake i
[ __ ] will kill you like
i [ __ ] loved it like i was all in on
it and like yeah it's
i know it's goofy and polarizing even
though i i know a lot of you
quote tweeted somebody recently i think
it was like comicbook.com or like people
are saying this is the best batman joker
scene ever and i'm like
i don't think it's the worst but the
best batman joker interaction ever i was
like
these people haven't seen any of this
they must not have all they have but i'm
just like i love this relationship watch
these things
it's uh you're right and there's so much
good stuff and it and that's why i loved
it i think it's just because it was
cool it's exactly what you're talking
about mark like i thought it was a cool
thing it was a cool
flash you know flash forward again
though when you start deconstructing
this right like
even though again even i'm arguing with
past gregory even talking to pastor i
guess it's like
this conversation of five films and so i
guess
eventually in film five we would have
found out why batman's having these
visions like i don't
i don't have the answers for you on that
and why like batman would have the
vision
in the cave in batman be superman but
then he wakes up from it but then papers
are floating down so it's like what is
the real reality here and where is this
going like
it serves to like oddly
kind of ruin the finale of the movie
which is
you think your heroes have won but the
thing that was supposed to do which is
we saved the world we saved the day we
kept apocalypse at bay
yeah us i mean it's oh you know we
didn't because look this is going to
happen
according to the text of this movie this
is going to happen which means
nothing you did did what you thought it
was going to do and
get that as tragedy but it's weird
to be ending a movie like this that
somehow neuters your heroes's
entire dramatic arc in the same picture
i almost feel like a better ending in
terms of what we're talking about mark
would have been
somehow taking the vision cyborg has in
the ship and putting it here
right where there is that moment of like
we did it guys high five hero poses this
is great and then somehow victor sees
the no this is actually what was
this is what was meant to happen all
along you are bringing about the end of
you know existence and then have that
like oh my god we have to get ready for
this fight we have to get ready for the
next big thing
yeah like or you then cut to uc dark
side
like you've been back on [ __ ]
apocalypse and you're with darkseid
and it's like rather the fleet we can't
we have to do it the old ways and you're
like
oh [ __ ] that bad guy is coming this is
amazing
instead of oh you know we're gonna lose
we lost in fact
and then marcia manhunter shows up to
say hey i'm not going to tell you my
name but i've gone by the name martian
manhunter
i'm around like okay yeah i'm sorry i
didn't help where i'm sure you might
have been able to use like family you
could do super cool stuff before but i
heard there was going to be fire and i
don't swim with
swastikas launch a nuke and kill
superman and you're still like nah i'm
not going to come out and do it not yet
oh my god you guys got this yeah
i with that that the batman v joker
scene um
i know that that was shot afterwards
that was one of the things that it was
like i know the context of that and i
keep trying to remove that from the way
that i'm talking about it is
understanding the context of like
well he thought he was gonna get to have
this conversation later in another film
but he still wanted to include it so he
put it in here it just was so weird and
out of place
like just like i get that i know who
joker is
but what does he serve to this story
whatsoever like it was just
so strange to have it in there um and
there were some
themes in there that i liked where where
i actually thought that batman saying i
will [ __ ] kill you was a massive
downside and i was like no no no no no
stop doing that but that's uh the purest
in me probably
it just and i do think that that is the
same of the ending bruce wayne's house
very cool um love the glass windows you
have everywhere sir
great visuals there but like even the
context of him showing up at the end
there is really strange and
a lot of the superman context in general
like the choice to revive him
um and and the entire world seemingly
or at least them never discussing how
the entire world
kind of hated him at that point and saw
him as this massive foreign threat
i feel like they just kind of like had
no conversation about the ramifications
of bringing someone back from the dead
uh and what he would do and that it
could turn out badly and how everyone
would have a problem with that like it
was just a big thing to do what they're
all just like
yes it okay let's do it and i understand
the
motivation tying into the mother boxes
and thinking that they wouldn't be
active if they saw him that he was there
and that it would protect them or
whatever like i understand that but it
was like there's
been very little conversation about this
resurrection
that we're doing here yeah right wow
you know they i feel like there's the i
enjoy that art there's the dissenting
opinion even on the ship right like this
is a bad idea let's not do this but even
when they were like
gathered around uh a mother box right
and before they go to the show
jacqueline's wearing his
scarf for some reason i was so annoyed
about what he was wearing in that scene
and flash right is like am i going to be
the one that has to say that sounds
crazy and cyborg does it
yeah right there is where you have a
conversation about bringing someone back
to life
and like what are you doing and like i
thought they handled
the grave robbing scene better than the
whedon cut yeah but it's still
not a hundred percent there i was like
you we get the thing of you know like
we could do this in a nanosecond like
yeah but in the uh
like he was my hero you know and they
start a little bit of the
you know seriousness of what they're
doing but then they still get like
you know the wonder woman you know when
she go for me which is a great line a
great conversation like
she's five thousand years old
everybody's younger than her like oh
that's great but it's still this thing
of like you're digging up a corpse in
smallville right now like i still feel
like
maybe you don't show that like with them
loading it in and being slow and then
bringing it out like i liked all that
and stuff there's
a weird juxtaposition about that but
yeah for like the you know ramifications
of the world i think in their world
and correct me if you didn't tell me if
you didn't read it this way my whole
but my take has been that in him dying
and
lex's plot being revealed and him giving
his life it seems like everybody came
around on him and it was one of those
they don't know they have to
gone kind of thing with the you know if
you see his memorial look around you and
then in london
they had the flag yeah and even um
suicide squad right where amanda
waller's like talking about a world
about superman and everybody's in
mourning
i think they they got it too late once
they were like oh man he didn't blow up
the capitol because that'd be a weird
thing to do
yeah that was definitely uh the implica
the capital thing was and i still like
that scene too but
uh the there was definitely an
implication that there was some morning
i still feel like it's
again like we you said earlier it's very
hard to go straight from everyone sees
him as a tremendous foreign threat to
immediately
without seeing any of that context in
this film everyone being like
should bring him back from the dead just
a lot of problems
in in this world everybody's mother's
name is martha that's true
they all relate they all relate yeah hey
but
one quick shout out to uh the one and
only martha kent in this film right
where uh uh
why am i diane diane elaine right uh
like
when she's uh talking to lois right in
the apartment and stuff
i was watching this i'm like why is she
turning her accent up to nine
why is she calling perry white mr perry
like
this is all really weird for martha and
then she leaves and she's marching and i
was like oh that's [ __ ] good
that's good that he was like i know
enough to piece it together and play off
of
lois's emotions of who she is but i
don't know the actual minute details are
like that's pretty good
yeah i like that maybe you guys can
clarify a thing i think for me
which is um steppenwolf
has this whole like when he's talking to
to decide and
i guess then conveying that information
to the dark side
he says something like there are no
kryptonians here
the path is clear or whatever yeah
um why would they be concerned about
kryptonians because there's really only
one who's superman
and they've never met him before the
mother boxes are never encountered
paul before and there could be a
billions kryptonians on krypton or even
in their world
like weird we're going to go off and and
like plant flags phased
none of them had powers so how is his
death
somehow a trigger to invite invasion
when nobody knew who he was he literally
was doing this for like 45 minutes
[Laughter]
like in learn of steel like was the
first time he shows up at superman
and so like i was listening to that part
of it which seems is the inciting event
for the whole movie is
this dude dies the mother boxes wake up
and here we go
yeah i don't have a great answer for you
i have two different reads on it
right where if we got really granular
with it right
krypton had been out and exploring and
going on those giant ships right and
trying to colonize worlds
i don't know if there was other worlds
they found that all of them they say in
man of steel right none of them worked
out like they all died so
theoretically that's not the actual take
on it but maybe they were out there and
they've run a foul of dark side before
and stopped them
and then yeah here it would be i'm with
you right of like
okay they stayed away from earth because
superman was there
but again to your point he's been there
for all of a hot minute like you know
it's not like that's what kept them away
for decades or whatever
but his death cry wakes up the boxes and
does the thing it's i'm with you like i
don't fully grasp that one either and so
there are no kryptonians no lanterns i
would be like well no kryptonians
because somehow they knew he was there
even though they
they didn't know he was there but then
the boxes kind of knew they were there
but then they weren't talking to the
boxes
so like the boxes sensed that they were
protected by him even though they didn't
know he was i think so
yeah because i thought they said the
kryptonian rather than the kryptonians i
could be wrong about that
um but that's how i read that is the
kryptonian i thought they were referring
to superman
singular i agree that it's still pretty
weird but i i
i assumed that that was some kind of
like the boxes figured out this power
and they inferred it from the boxes
i think maybe
i mean yeah i mean silas stone did wake
up a box to help transform his son
into frankenstein and so maybe while
that happened
the box had noticed some [ __ ] but
maybe i don't know if they can
communicate i mean keep in mind that's
not the box that phones home right it's
the amazonian
box that gets woken up at the very end
with the cry that calls them back to say
hey this is what's going on where we are
because keep in mind too that's the
other thing of this of like they've
forgotten about where earth is right
they're they're they they don't there's
mother boxes there they got dropped they
don't know they forgot dark side took a
axe to the chest and then bounced out
and they were in such a hurry
they just shot away and they were like
oh [ __ ] where were we i don't remember
[ __ ] i left something on that surface
god damn it
like little bit important that you left
on the surface it's very important
i still feel like overall again it made
a lot more sense to me than justice
league did it really did like
across the board there are like my main
criticism is character development stuff
or even relationship stuff but like even
the mother boxes stuff beforehand i was
like i don't get any of it
my biggest beef is with the way that it
was told i think there's so much
exposition in this movie
uh that it's exhausting in some parts
like i really do think gal gadot's
delivery of the mother box exposition
that feels like it runs for 10 minutes
long is just like you don't sound like
you're having a conversation
yeah you don't sound like you're having
a conversation with bruce wayne
you sound like you're reading a script
and i don't know how gal gadot has
fallen into that trap
of that being that long and that
uninteresting like sure it's visually
interesting some of those battles are
really really cool the stuff you're
looking at is visually impressive but
man that much exposition could we have
figured out any other way to tell some
of those pieces and it happens more than
once as well
it's a lot i mean i think like i i came
away
from the snyder cut you know and and
what was clearly the
process of the creation of the snyder
cut and why it exists at all
you know which is zack snyder's shot
what seems to be at least
three hours and 50 minutes worth of
footage like we don't know what else is
on the cutting room floor that didn't
make it in here
but a massive amount of footage and then
had a personal capacity and had to step
away
and warner brothers felt a certain way
about the movie rightly or wrongly they
felt like listen
this we don't feel like this iteration
of it is the one that we can
somehow cut down to two hours and 25
minutes and release to the world
we need to do some work to it somebody's
got to finish this movie
that was going to happen regardless um
they think the error was
they chose the wrong guy you know i
think that that
joss and maybe was you know him coming
off of um
sort of avengers age of ultron and i
think anybody who was paying attention
to that press tour
saw that he was exhausted and furious
and just done
with making superhero movies and so he
did it like i'll pick on this one too
even though i clearly am not in the
headspace to be able to do a good job at
this
and kind of screwed it up um i think
that a different filmmaker might have
been able to get under the hood and see
what was here
and see the spot welding you needed to
do in ways that were not offensive to
anybody
in ways that clarified a lot of those
storytelling weird boondoggles that get
lost in
and then made you know using this
framework made a more cohesive story
um but i think that it's it is telling
that like yes
all four hours of this make more sense
than the jazz cut did
but don't actually function at least to
me as like
legit drama where we have character
evolution
and and i agree narrative propulsion
it is just it's an assembly of stuff we
shot you're not quite yet a movie
and some of that stuff's really cool i
mean it's awesome i mean
there's moments like this iteration of
the finale
i i legit got chills when superman shows
up
you know in a way that i didn't in the
previous edition like i love the darks
of men fight and i still love the
the eye look like there's moments in
this movie that i still think pop and
have vibration to him
and i think zach is in amazing he's got
a fantastic eye and has a real gift
for sort of orchestrating this chaos in
ways that are clearly understood like
it's not michael bay at work like this
is a dude who knows where your eye is
supposed to be looking and knows where
he's supposed to be following
but it seems as if the the connective
tissue
is where the movie needed the most help
that uh
that wasn't rendered honestly by the
previous version of it well i still
think if you need four hours to do it
that's probably an issue with your
storytelling
and the issue like you know especially
talking about connective tissue right is
again how snyder viewed what he was
going to do with all these films
and how warner brothers at least in the
beginning said that was okay
and that's you know the very beginning
when i was talking about like my problem
isn't with snyder like again like i
don't know i mean like you know
i would love a bright superman i would
love a lot of color i would love uh
the batman we're getting with pattinson
looks awesome stuff like that like
i would love all that in my dc cinematic
universe but
i more than anything wanted wanted to
see his vision all the way through
because we started down that journey
because you i think you
know when you get to suicide squad and i
remember watching those
trailers and be like holy this looks
like this is going to be awesome and
then going in there and leaving and
being like what the [ __ ] did i just
watch how did the
how did they mess that up that badly and
then you get all this thing of like well
it was supposed to be tying into the
snyder stuff
it was supposed to be more dark side and
apocalypse they ripped it out the last
second they put it
like oh my god and like you see that
then get to here where you know
zach has the tragedy and the vanity fair
piece is so good going through all this
far better than i ever could in a few
sentences
but goes through this tragedy just
doesn't want to fight with wb anymore it
bounces right and they bring in
joss and i think it's no matter who you
would have brought in to do that
they were set up to fail great because
it was hey
come in and give us the mcu like it's i
think you look at what
like that movie became and it's just
clear that's why it went that way
because they were like
please get us to the light literally get
us back to that put in all the jokes
have superman race flash have him be in
the blues and the reds and stuff like
that like let's get there please help us
get there and
by that point like you the train was out
of the station like
that that's what my problem this whole
thing is like right now
like you can't watch zack snyder's
justice league
and separate it from the story
surrounding it you know what i mean his
his daughter's suicide this joss whedon
stuff all these different things and so
more than ever and it sucks now is like
i just wish this we were living in the
reality where they let him do this
where we get the next two films where we
see it become the nightmare universe
where we see
you know batman give his life to save
lois where we see uh
clark and lois have this kid where we
see credits roll and they're like cool
that was the story and then go back
and again for better or worse then go
back and be like oh that's what he's
doing with the nightmare sequence and oh
yeah this is four hours and it feels
like at times like you were talking
about character development and
is it here is the mission like there are
there
is but it's just not the normal what we
see in a film of what we expect out of a
film right like i love that by the end
of the
the film you have that moment with a um
flash in aquaman right where he's like
all right arthur option a or option b
and he puts on a he's like
he puts bomb b's like let me see a again
and then even the conversation right
where they're wrestling with the fact
that cyborg has to give up
cyborg is the only person who can do
this and they're having a conversation
and
he and flash like to aquaman like i
thought you didn't want to be here he's
like i never said that or i never said i
don't care whatever it was like
they're building those little blocks
that i would have loved to have seen
grow into the next two movies now again
i simp for dc like if they they could
have said snyder cuts eight hours and i
would have been like
let's go like i'm down let's so like i'm
not the guy to talk about like what you
can do with that thing but
the snyder cut is this art house picture
that has all these ideas shoved in it
and
even now being done with it having
watched it twice already i'm like
god i want to see what the rest would be
yeah
you know and i think to your point
the blame doesn't lie with
death truly he had a vision absolutely
it doesn't really lie with just
because to your point no matter who you
put in that position is probably going
to fail
you know a different filmmaker might
have felt failed less
you know should have felt more but it
was always a losing proposition
but i think you know to your point if
warner brothers believed in this enough
to let him
shoot all of it you know whereas if you
looked at that script and said hey this
isn't working for us
we need to we need you to do some
different things at the beginning like
you're building a house that's built on
faulty you know plans and designs
so let's correct the plan first
then i think you don't have to wait that
long for the stuff that you didn't get
you know it's not built
in in such a way that is forestalling
your appreciation of these ideas and
letting
you know a little too much putting too
much down down the road
to hope that in movie three or four we
finally get the answers to these things
it's like
yeah get under the hood early yeah the
measure twice cut once
version of it and it's like hey we
didn't measure this right and so now we
have four hours of footage that we don't
know what to do with
right and it's them being so reactionary
to everything right where you know i
mean i remember
uh you know after bvs right you know man
of steel was
oh my god superman doesn't kill and also
they destroyed metropolis there'd be
thousands of dead that's outrageous it's
a comic book movie that shouldn't happen
batman v superman is warner brothers
getting involved in making sure
when doomsday smashes into striker's
island they go that's abandoned don't
worry and also when they're fighting in
downtown metropolis anderson
cooper is like luckily it's after hours
so it's pretty much
abandoned right like they get around
that and then it's like batman's
superman finishes and people like
superman doesn't smile it's not funny
and if you remember for
justice league when it was still zack
snyder's justice league years ago
it was they invited everyone to set on
that first press tour when they filmed
the
wait what's your superpower i'm rich and
he catches the batarang and does all
that they were trying to show that
there's levity like
it's just the it's the you know as much
as we don't want to compare to mcu
it is so warner brothers wanting mcu
but then not wanting to put in the work
so going
you your next one you want to do batman
v superman and introduce justice league
go for it and then that's like oh god
and then they keep trying to change it
they're laying the track but then also
trying to get it to go to the left when
they were going right
had to be way slower and needed way way
way more guidance and i i
i largely agree like overall with your
point greg like
i personally agree with the point that
this movie you can't look at it without
the surrounding context of how it was
made and how it came out and like the
fact that it was
you know this this guy who went through
something awful trying to
figure out how to put the pieces of what
he expected to be much longer together
but the truth is there are people
watching this movie who
don't know any of that like that is a
thing um
lots of people who don't know the the
context behind it
uh who are also going to look at a four
hour run time which is you know
astronomical for a film uh and be like
what why
is this this long and i also understand
the idea that it's like well just don't
watch it
uh if you don't know this context or if
you don't want to watch a four-hour film
but when they're pushing it this hard i
think it just invites that kind of
criticism like from people who aren't
familiar with all of that context and
like everything that you said about like
wishing he could have seen his vision
out is exactly how i feel about
assassin's creed
i think about it all the time i was like
you'd set me up
up until basically brotherhood where i
was like i'm gonna get the story of the
people who came before
and what were all these people doing
then they just cut it all off and
they're like black flag
pirates and i was like i like the
pirates but you dunked on the sci-fi
trilogy that you were setting up that i
was so invested in and yeah
i fully respect that but i also just
feel like you know that that context
can't
remove some of the the criticisms people
have overall because it's it is still a
film you know as a standalone piece that
some people will see not knowing any of
that
uh where of course four hours to tell a
very simple
overall it's not it's not like it's that
simple but four hours to tell a story
that doesn't leave you coming away with
like mark kept alluding to this
big dramatic piece it's it's just a long
time to leave me with not a tremendous
amount of feeling other than the popcorn
moments that i really really really
enjoyed like that i found really fun
the comic book-y stuff um hey i like
some of the slo-mo he gets a lot of
flack for it
it's overused but some of it i think is
very fun to look at
it's just it's just a lot you're asking
of people who may not know the context
and even of the people who do know the
context i feel like you don't leave
fulfilled you just sleep kind of bummed
that you didn't get
the alternate universe that you wanted
yeah it is very much i remember talking
to uh to kevin smith
about it what is today monday so this
would have been last night maybe i don't
know how time works
who knows anyway and he watched it yeah
and he watched it with his wife
and but his wife knows nothing about any
of this so he was he became wikipedia
while she's sitting down there watching
it's like okay so this is a mother box
okay so this is dark side this is this
this is granny goodness this is what
this means okay so
cyborg like if you have to explain all
of this to a person who doesn't know
then the movie's not doing its job like
the movie should be the only text you
need to understand the movie
yeah and if it's not getting you there
then there's some problem with
how that movie is conveying the text
yeah compare that again to
and i know mark didn't want to i will go
all day on this compare
that to when i went back to chicago the
night end game came out and watched it
with
my cousin who has two teenage daughters
and my cousin when i was growing up did
not care about my superhero stuff at all
but
when we were on the way to that theater
she was talking to me about iron man and
she was talking to me about how they're
going to time travel and she was like
she knew it cold because the movies for
20 some movies had done such a great job
of giving her a universe from
the simplest thing of i am iron man tony
stark all the way too
here's thanos like i like how do you
explain that to someone right
and this quick of a succession that's
what you're seeing where it's like
to me haven't explained to my friends
what's a mother box oh well let me tell
you
let me tell you about boom tubes unless
you know what i mean like
there's a reason mcu has been so
successful and is so
dominant it's because it does a great
job at exploring this stuff it's the
point that now you're getting
falcon and winter soldier and we're
literally saying man the avengers can't
get a loan
that's [ __ ] awesome i love that
that's how i think it should be and you
compare that then to
here's the flash you don't know how he
got his powers but you know he you don't
know his dad
he's trying to get a job and this girl
he likes and that's that's iris by the
way oh you know who iris is let me you
know it's like what are we doing like
there's so many moving things right now
yeah you know it's it's the perils of
trying to jumpstart a universe
yeah and and i think that that warner
brothers i mean going forward
seems to have taken that lesson kind of
close to heart which is
we're not going to try this anymore
we're just going to do what we do
best which is empower filmmakers to tell
singular stories
will there be sequels of those stories
sure will they all connect
loosely will you have to have seen them
all to make sense
not at all you know like you're going to
get a joker and a batman and probably
another batman who's going to show up in
flashpoint
and that's cool and hey we're going to
get us a ton of movie that's awesome
how's the time with anything else
doesn't who cares
make a good movie that's the first job
and then if you can connect them great
but if you're not accomplishing that
first job you know i i think warner
brothers just figured out like
let's do the thing that we do better
than marvel does like they own this
space they refer to the door they
figured out how to do it
trying to compete on their turf is
futile so we're going to do this over
here we can do black adam that's cool
right
yeah yeah the rock's cool the rock's
nice yeah
yeah i just wish they'd slowed it down
for sure but i still feel like overall
like
considering the production hell this was
better than i expected going into it
um in it it is four hours and i don't
feel like i was satisfied narratively in
that four hour span of time of course
it's hard to say when you've already
watched
a very similar film and this just adds
two origin three origin stories kind of
into it
um but it was better than i thought it
would be considering how hot it had to
have been
to actually put together uh i i believe
snyder didn't get paid for it
as well he declined like that's that's
wild it's definitely like a monumental
feat
um but i i do wonder how like someone
hearing all this hype about the snyder
cut and going into
going into it and watching it having
never seen any of the previous like
snyder verse films
if it would make any sense because i
feel like most of it did but again only
by a massive exposition dumps
all the time it's a lot it's a lot to
understand
it is i look forward to the day and and
it's coming soon enough because these
things always happen
where there's some like 19 year old kid
in
film fool who looked at these four hours
and was like you know what i can do it
i can get this down to 220. you know i
can i can like the zack schneider
that remixes are coming and i'm
fascinated to see that because how often
do you get four hours of raw footage of
a movie
that's like just executed incredibly
well on every technical front
that just needs some more love you know
like and and watching
people kind of tarantino this movie and
get under the phone oh yeah
and deliver you know you know the the
the what was it copa grace's
cut of phantom menace that like pulled
out
all of the jar jar stuff and just like
oh okay i'd like to see this version i'm
curious about it
like how does this become the bedrock
upon which further future storytellers
find a way to hone their crowd like that
with no other reason
i think that there's some real value in
that but i think there is other value in
it for sure
but i look forward to that where do you
get to host that stuff if you were if i
were to re-cut the schneider cup
like where would anyone ever publish
that without being destroyed
the dark corners of vimeo
that's what happened it's a thing like
those was that the 4k
restoration of star wars where like
somebody goes in and like
literally from an original prince has
digitally restored star wars
back to its it's got the grain and all
of the like the weird film flickers like
this is how you would have seen it in
1977.
you can't buy that really you can't just
distribute that like it becomes a thing
that gets passed around
like legend and lore and then there's
something kind of uh
fitting about that for something like
this
yeah i also feel like it was just like a
nice closure of a story um
even if it you know it was for zack
snyder even if it wasn't necessarily for
the justice league themselves or all the
things going on at the universe itself
um definitely you know a long road
coming
uh it seems like people in the chat are
very mixed on it some people are very
upset with us
for being too critical um naturally hey
opinions if you liked it i fully support
that
i am with you loving the things you love
um
definitely no beef with anyone loving
anything i don't love
um even though i did still enjoy it um
but you know you're allowed to like and
dislike things yeah i did too i did have
have a fun time
especially considering it yeah before we
go do you guys that's how i was
good i was gonna say that's how i knew i
was
like a dc fan or whatever fan boy
on another level it's where when it when
it when it got into like i was like
has it been four hours already i'm like
oh man something's wrong with me
i expect you to watch it across multiple
sittings let's keep going yeah no it
wasn't it wasn't hard to get through
just
the only thing that really graded on me
again the exposition so much law dump
um and the slo-mo sometimes i was like
do we need it for the football game too
like did it have to be here as well just
sometimes a little bit excessive
but i appreciate he has a style and he
sticks to it
um mark did you have any more closing
thoughts that you wanted to share before
we go
um no just that you know when it's all
said and done
um this this isn't a disafter you know i
mean
no matter how one can say they feel
about it you know no matter how
sort of ambivalent it might be about
parts of it it feels very much like
you know uh they they rescued a
stalemate from the jaws of defeat
you know i don't think it's a win but i
definitely don't think it's a it's an
l either um it is it is a curio and i'm
glad it exists
um if for no other reason then just to
see
your point his vision finally realized
like what was it
like and now we know greg
yeah uh for me right like i really
enjoyed it and i'm glad it exists and i
think it was tim on kind of funny that
put it like and he was in a negative
sense with it but he's like
he's like is it a is it a good film is
it this he's like it's art
and i think it's art in a way you don't
see ever with superhero movies this kind
of
way where the story of what was
happening behind the scenes this the
story of what's happened
but you know after the fact where it ran
where all this different stuff gets
rolled into the conversation to make it
something
uh bigger than it is and i think you
know that works for it and works for me
and it does
what i love in comic books movies games
media
where we're having this conversation and
talking about the
motivations of characters whether
they're good or bad or these
awesome moments all these things for it
you know mark said you know he didn't
know if it was a it didn't think it was
a win like i think it is a win
for zack snyder for the fans for
on even though they don't want it warner
brothers right because they didn't make
good on this and even though they're out
there today saying
that we have no plan we're not going to
restore the snyder verse this was the
end of that thing
i will believe it when i see it i
remember when you told me there was no
cider cut
i wouldn't be surprised to see this
continued as uh at least get the linux
two movies that we were supposed to get
right as
animated editions or whatever not in
their cinematic universe but
following up on this or you know some
mini series on hbo or something like
that but
the hope i have is that you know
warner brothers learns their lesson from
this where what they should have done
is like guess what everybody we loved
man of steel so much we're gonna have
zach do four more pictures
and that will be all in the same
universe and then that will end and we
will do other stuff side by side
i hope flashpoint is the fix to all this
where he you know goes through
we get michael keaton the general
audience understands what we all
understand from crisis on infinite earth
whether you're old like me in the comic
book
or the cw show and it's like hey guess
what there's a multiverse here and we
can put up anything we want and
here's this new super girl you've never
heard of because the universe has
emerged but we're putting her over
like blow it all up make people
understand that way you can have the
batman going
and then michael keaton's batman beyond
happening over here and then there is
something happening this
snyder versus just roll with it and
let's let's make more crazy fun
superhero movies
i can get behind that um well yeah i
feel like
it it was good chatting to you guys
about this uh
i feel like i kind of want to watch it
again which is not a thing i ever
thought i would say about a for a whole
film but i'll just give it a bit i think
we can wait a few months before we get
there
um but for now mark where can people
find you
uh they can find me on the internets at
mark bernardin
m-a-r-c-b-e-r-n-a-r-d-i-n on both
twitter and instagram
i have uh taken off the new facebook
from orbit
it's the only way to be sure i respect
that a lot uh how about you greg
you can go find me at youtube.com kinda
funny we have a show called
in review where we watch each and every
superhero movie and review and rank them
right now we're going through godzilla
we got reactions to falcon the winter
soldier before we enter that on mcu
and of course we will be all over
invincible this friday
very cool thank you guys for joining me
and thank you all for watching uh we
will see you next time